mais on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
anne nivat journaliste indépendant doit
reporter de guerre merci anne d'être
avec nous face à vous virginie herz
rebonjour virginie virginia ce qui
représente notamment le magazine actuel
sur france 24 rencontres américano
chinoises à haut niveau ça s'est passé
en italie à rome le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale de joe biden jake
sullivan s'est entretenu avec le plus
haut responsable du parti communiste
chinois pour la diplomatie yang jiechi
au menu des discussions à n'en pas
douter les informations du new york
times selon lesquelles moscou aurait
demandé à pékin de lui fournir des
équipements militaires pour faire la
guerre en ukraine une aide économique
aussi pour l'aider à surmonter les
sanctions internationales côté chinois
on dément ces informations du quotidien
américain écouter
les etats unis ont récemment diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes la position
de la chine sur la question de l'ukraine
a été claire et cohérente
on comprend pas d'intervention et de la
chine 2 quelle aide est il question
d'ingénieurs vous l'avais dit la demande
d'être serez militaire économique et
financière alors militaire pas l'envoi
de soldats mais d' équipements
militaires c'est ça paraît quand même
assez surprenant parce que s'il y a un
partenariat militaire renforcée entre la
russie et la chine depuis l'annexion
d'un crime et depuis 2014 ça va plutôt
dans le sens de moscou vers pékin l'a vu
les ventes d'armes et pas l'inversé le
soutien économique pourrait être plus
probable c'est pour compenser les
sanctions occidentales
il faut rappeler que depuis le premier
jour de guerre les chinois ont levé les
restrictions à l'importation de blé
russe par exemple et surtout le soutien
qui est probablement demander c'est le
soutien financier le soutien bancaire
les établissements chinois et le yuan
tout simplement pourrait servir de porte
de sortie aux russes qui ne peuvent plus
accéder au dollar ou encore à l'euro il
faut rappeler que plus de 13% des
réserves de devises de la banque
centrale russe sont en yuan alors en
rappelant que le 4 février dernier il ya
eu une rencontre si jean ping vladimir
poutine c'était pour lever exactement et
à ce moment là disait l'amitié je cite
entre les deux états est sans limite il
n'y a aucune zone la coopération soit
interdite certes mais est-ce que à ce
moment là les chinois avaient été
informés de l'invasion russe ou en tout
cas l'ampleur de cette guerre
certainement pas ça veut dire qu'en
termes de confiance ya peut-être un
problème est peut-être que les chinois
vont être un petit peu hésitant et il
faut rappeler aussi que des chinois ont
pas mal d'intérêt en ukraine donc voilà
à voir si effectivement ils vont
apporter cette aide qui aurait dit-on en
tout cas poussé la délicatesse jusqu'à
reporter c'est son intention d'envahir
l'ukraine a après les jeux olympiques
ont bien l'événement l'événement celle
ci c'est une information sur la délicate
en ehpad jeunes d'ailleurs ce qui l'est
c'est une supposition ils ont un
successeur ça changerait la donne la
chine aux côtés de la russie dans cette
crise oui bien sûr mais là je peux pas
faire des supputations ça n'est pas
possible ça permet de rompre l'isolément
faut quand même souligner historiquement
la retenue de la chine toujours
diplomatiquement la chine met un point
d'honneur à ne jamais prendre parti dont
on voit mal pourquoi la chine changerait
d'avis qu est ce qui ferait que là
aujourd'hui elle change d'avis même si
ça vient d'être souligné les le
l'entente est forte et elle l'est de
plus en plus au fil des années parce que
venir poutine a besoin de la chine a
besoin de ce partenaire économique qui
est au delà de ses frontières du fleuve
amour de ces milliers de kilomètres du
sud de la russie vers poutine et le
dirigeant chinois se sont rencontrés 38
fois depuis qu'ils sont l'un et l'autre
au pouvoir c'est quand même énorme mais
je veux dire que la chine donc si elles
s'expriment peu elle exprime quand même
elle l'a dit depuis le début de cette
guerre en ukraine son souci face à la
crise humanitaire la crise humanitaire
ce sont les mots qu'il a prononcés en
revanche les chinois ne parle pas de
guerre ni d'invasion donc ça ça va
plutôt bien c'est moins le sens des
russes exactement et il ya aussi
d'autres mots qui ont été prononcés par
les autorités chinoises récemment mais
qui sont très sibyllin on ne comprend
pas puisque la chine dit qu'elle
soutient la souveraineté et l'intégrale
in l'intégrité pardon territoriales mais
par l'hôtel de l'ukraine par l'hôtel de
la russie est ce que c'est sciemment peu
claires pour que justement elle n'est
pas véritablement s expliquer on ne sait
pas on en est là en tout cas valeo
admirer les skis je l'avais dit ici
d'ailleurs je crois mais je le répète
avait dès le départ quelques jours après
l'invasion de son pays ait eu cette
intelligence de d'exprimer justement
l'idée d'appeler la chine à l'aider lui
à aider l'ukraine ce qui ne s'était
jamais fait pourquoi la chine démons
virginie est réticente entrer dans le
conflit où il ya tout simplement pas
d'intérêt à aider moscou ah non il ya
dix ans qu'il ya plusieurs choses il ya
d'une part peut-être la menace des états
unis qui ont été réitérées là ce soir
dir si vous prenez trop position pour
les russes si vous les aidez à aider à
contourner les sanctions on peut nous
déployer toute une série de conséquences
et de sanction à notre tour ensuite il
faut rappeler que quand même
la chine dépend beaucoup de la santé de
l'économie mondiale or finalement ce
conflit c'est pas forcément dans son
intérêt que
qu'il continue et pour si j'ai une prime
plus précisément son intérêt à lui très
précisément en 2022 c'est de se faire
réélire tranquillement avec une
situation économique stable ça doit se
passer en automne en automne prochain
donc oui les russes et les chinois au
niveau des gouvernements ont la même
conception de la gouvernance sont contre
l'hégémonie américaine
mais les chinois vont surtout penser sur
le long terme et vont être comme
d'habitude extrêmement prudent à part
avoir des intérêts communs qui sont
faiblir les usa il ya quand même de
grandes différences entre la realpolitik
chinoise et la russe comme souvent les
régimes autoritaires ou nationalistes
l'armée russe qui n'exclut pas de
prendre le contrôle total des grandes
villes ukrainiennes déjà encerclé
prévient le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov est ce inquiétant au
contraire d'après vous à un bémol par
rapport aux positions jusque-là défendu
par moscou qui semblait prête à une
invasion totale a assez maximaliste
finalement on avait senti son enquête il
donnait pas de limite à son intervention
le signe qu'on est peut-être prêt
négocié côté russe est-ce qu'on peut le
percevoir comme ça non moi je suis très
inquiète très inquiète parce que on ne
connaît pas les buts de guerre de venir
poutine il ne les a jamais explicité
ralenti t-il est-ce qu'il ralentit
sciemment la prise de kiev est-ce que ou
est-ce qu'il est frustré par les erreurs
commises par son armée par les lignes de
ravitaillement qui ne fonctionne pas et
c et c'est parce qu'il avait justement
pas du tout compris ça c'est sûr ça il
ne l'a pas dit mais ça c'est sûr il
n'avait pas du tout saisi que les
ukrainiens pourrait lui tenir tête c'est
quand même gros mais c'est exactement ça
qui s'est passé 110 longs quand même sur
la mentalité devenir poutine aujourd'hui
où est-ce que son but de guerre c'est
ce qu'il est quand même en train de
faire en ce moment c'est à dire de
saisir toutes les villes du sud c'est à
dire sept nouveaux récits dont on a déjà
beaucoup parlé avec marioupol qui est
complètement saoul souvent bombardements
aujourd'hui et plus on arrive et on
arriverait à odessa voilà on arriverait
au dessin donc est ce que c'est ça sa
limite
il a des réserves il il a des réserves
il n'a pas encore envoyé tout le monde
on combat à vladimir poutine il a
des
professionnels il a fait appel justement
à mais celui qui fait le plus de zèle
autour de lui c'est ramzan kadyrov l'a
justement il ya eu effectivement saisi
jack circuler sur télégramme on le voit
dans un bâtiment accompagnés de soldats
en train d'étudier des plantes dans un
bâtiment un lit lui même présent sur le
terrain il se disait par mail en ukraine
alors ramzan kadyrov c'est le leader
tchétchène qui est évidemment propres
aux blés de mire poutine et de ce depuis
des années il a effectivement sur sa
chaîne télé grave aujourd'hui envoyé
cette vidéo mais il n'est pas à
l'extérieur donc on ne peut pas essayer
de comprendre exactement où il se trouve
il prétend qu'il est sur le sol
ukrainien alors c'est ça peut être aussi
de la vantardise parce que ça c'est la
nature de ce rayman kadirov en tout cas
le but de ramzan kadirov qui depuis le
départ depuis le lendemain de l'invasion
du 24 avait dit moi j'envoie mes hommes
c'est de montrer à vladimir poutine qui
il est qu'il est capable jusqu'au bout
de servir les intérêts de la russie pour
que en échange il continue à être le
président de cette république où je vous
rappelle s'est déroulée une guerre
sanglante et qui est terminée sans
vraiment l'être puisque tout le monde
vit dans la terreur et qu' il n'y a pas
de liberté
des droits ni des femmes nées des
homosexuels en tchétchénie aujourd'hui
et il y a donc des tchétchènes qui
combattent comme lui aux côtés de
l'armée russe mais il ya aussi des
tchétchènes avec une efficacité relative
c'est la surprise aux siens s'agissant
des tchétchènes on ne connaît pas encore
la loquacité mais en tout cas elle est
aux côtés d'un virus l'armée russe s'est
quand même huit fois plus nombreuses que
l'armée ukrainienne sur le terrain mais
il ya aussi des tchétchènes qui
combattent côté ukrainien
ça je voudrais le dire aussi c'est plus
compliqué mais ça existe et ça existe
depuis 2000 14 depuis le dôme basse il y
avait une division du nom de gerrard ou
des f le premier indépendant le premier
président indépendantiste tchétchène qui
a toujours combattu et qui existe encore
ses divisions côté armées ukrainiennes
c'est-à-dire qui combat les séparatistes
pro-russes du donbass donc on retrouve
finalement sur le terrain ukrainien la
guerre en tchétchénie et en attendant
les premières frappes tombe sur pied un
génie oui absolument kiev alors on sait
que la semaine dernière les autorités
russes ont dit que leur but n'était pas
de faire tomber le gouvernement
ukrainien et de s'en prendre à zelensky
en particulier est ce que c'est quand
même finalement une façon de mettre la
pression de démoraliser la population
parce que c'est ça aussi c'est une
guerre aussi qui se joue sur l'usure on
a beaucoup remarqué souligné le
patriotisme la capacité de résistance de
la population ukrainienne mais à force
effectivement cette population peut être
quand même relativement
décourager
vous avez dit tout à l'heure on ne
connaît pas les buts de guerre delà des
meilleures poutines cela dit depuis
maintenant des mois quand même il répète
que un il veut la démilitarisation de
l'ukraine il ne veut pas que l'ukraine
rentrer dans l'otan il est pour
l'autonomie enfin l'indépendance des
républiques de l'est du de l'ukraine ça
peut s'étendre un petit peu plus loin ce
sont des intérêts stratégiques sont des
intérêts stratégiques et meilleurs
termes a manqué ce qu'il veut et
militairement il va continuer
certainement à pousser jusqu'à ce qu'ils
aient au moins l'un d'eux c'est l'un des
objectifs qui sont en train de tomber
une ville voilà c'est ça ils n'ont pas
fait tomber une grande ville sauf carson
qui est donc dans le sud dans l'anneau
borussia mais kiev si kiev tombe d'abord
ça sera blanc avec des dizaines voire
des centaines de milliers de victimes
civiles est
également il faut ensuite occupé la
ville il faut la tenir est ce que est ce
que l'armée russe en est capable d'après
ce qu'on connaît de l'armée russe
ailleurs c'est quand même très compliqué
tout où les militaires le savent à quel
point c'est compliqué donc est-ce qu'il
veut véritablement aller ce côté là où
est ce qu'il veut continuer à nous
terroriser dans ce cas là c'est réussi
en nous faisant croire qu'il veut
prendre kiev mais toute façon qu'ils
aient fait symbolique et puis à kiev il
ya le président volleyeurs zelensky qui
lui continue a symboliquement et
courageusement tenir tête et a exprimé
le fait qu'il est là et il a commencé à
dire lui même les demi-heures zelensky
que c'est pas qu'il avait terriblement
vie lui tu parles est venu à poutine
mais qu'il fallait parler avenir poutine
et continuer à parler avec la boutique
donc en fait le grand changement là ça
serait est ce que on va avoir une
rencontre entre les deux chefs d'état
est pour l'instant de la dîmière poutine
a dit que ça se fera seulement free les
autres pourparlers aboutisse à quelque
chose merci merci anne nivat merci
également à virgin hier on va à présent
va marquer une courte pause on se
retrouve dans six minutes pour un
nouveau joueur
[Musique]